I'm Brenna. I am Udacity's Community Manager. So I work with our students to
tell everyone about our classes, and support
everyone and celebrate our successes. I have
an Android. It's pretty [SOUND] janky. It's
old, [SOUND] and it loses power almost
immediately if you turn the Internet on. So, I'm offline most of the time.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> And
so if I'm lost, I will turn on the internet and I will go on to Google
Maps and if I really want to check my e-mail I'll turn it on by you know, it's
a, it's a big decision. Probably my favorite app is
2048. We recently had a class called make your
own 2048 and I along with pretty much everyone in the office got addicted
to playing 2048. So I'll probably spend like
hours and hours playing 2048 on my phone. [LAUGH]
That was definitely worth losing battery. The last
app I uninstalled was Twitter because when I turn
the Internet on with my phone Twitter is a total energy hog and will not let any
other app do anything until it's updated like
all 80 million tweets that Udacity's gotten in the
meantime, and so it literally kills my phone. So
I had to take it off. I install it every
now and then if I need to tweet from my
phone, but in general, I can tweet from other devices.